it is May 9th 2022 and you are watching
the code report for the last 10 years
people have been saying there's a bubble
in Tech and finally it looks like that
bubble is starting to pop or maybe it's
just a minor correction this is fine I'm
okay with the events that are unfolding
currently nobody really knows let's take
a look at some of the bad news that has
been piling up over the last few months
and find out what it means for
developers Tech workers and startup
Founders in a video about a year ago I
pointed out how companies like Snowflake
and Shopify were absurdly overvalued as
of today Shopify is down over 75 percent
and they're not the only one virtually
every high-flying Tech stock that ipoed
over the last five years is down
anywhere from 50 to 90 percent the
common theme around these companies is
that they don't actually make any money
they may have a lot of Revenue growth
but don't actually turn a profit and
that means they need money to burn
through to survive unfortunately the
transitory inflation wasn't actually
transitory and now the Federal Reserve
has had to turn the Easy Money spigot
off in addition many of these companies
exploded during the pandemic and Now
growth is hitting a wall because
pandemic mode has been turned on
now if you're a bag holder for one of
these companies that sucks but the thing
that's a little more worrisome is that
when companies lose money this rapidly
they need to start cutting expenses and
one of the best ways to do that is via
layoffs
last week we saw high profile companies
like Robin Hood and work rise Implement
layoffs and meta AKA Facebook
implemented a hiring freeze that's not a
good sign for a company that wants to
put us all in the metaverse now the big
picture as of today still looks very
strong but the dynamic seems to be
rapidly changing it could stop right
here but it could also get a lot worse
and I think we should all be aware of
that possibility now you might think the
answer to this is Bitcoin and crypto
Bitcoin has also crashed 50 in the last
six months and like I predicted in my
web 3 video this decline has gone hand
in hand with a decline in hype for web 3
and nfts these may be amazing
revolutionary Technologies long term but
it's a lot harder to have fun when
everybody's losing money now another
group of people affected are the startup
Founders especially those who depend on
Venture Capital many people have called
out the whole VC system as a giant Ponzi
scheme made possible by Easy Money
investor sentiment is way down
valuations are going down and less
capital is being deployed in all
likelihood this means you'll have a
harder time securing funding in the near
future and companies that have already
been funded will likely need to cut
costs in and increase growth if they
want to see additional funding in the
future and zombie companies that have no
path to profitability will probably not
survive very much longer the days of
companies like Fast which had 60 million
or no 60 000 in annual recurring revenue
and 500 employees are over fast and
become profitable fast enough and was
discontinued in April the last time
things looked this bad was early 2020
but that time the central banks were
able to print trillions upon trillions
of dollars the rich got way richer and
we got the leftover crumbs in the form
of stemis which we're now paying for
many times over in the form of inflation
now I realize this video sounds very
pessimistic but just remember that
things could always get a lot worse like
they could start World War III at any
moment and draft us all into the front
lines until that happens though I will
continue to learn to code and try to
create value for other people because
often the best opportunities emerge out
of downturns like this this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one